bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
au parlement européen à strasbourg pour
une nouvelle émission d'europe hebdo et
dans cette émission reportage direction
la belgique en europe les pv qui
s'arrêtent aux frontières c'est fini il
faut savoir que plus de 20% des
véhicules flashés sur les routes
françaises ont des plaques étrangères et
bien désormais un ressortissant de
l'union européenne qui a commis une
infraction routière dans un pays
européen autre que le sien pourra
désormais être tracé jusque chez lui 1
s'il veut une directive qui s'applique
depuis trois mois
question est ce que cette directive
tient vraiment la route cela va-t-il
mettre fin à l'impunité des conducteurs
étrangers sûrement pas c'est ce que nous
allons voir dans cette émission mais
avant un tout autre sujet l'ukraine
l'ukraine s'enfonce un peu plus dans la
crise certains craignent une guerre
civile entre d'un côté les pro européens
et de l'autre côté les pro russes et les
européens dans tout cela les européens
qui ont contribué à la déclencher cette
crise est bien pour la résoudre ils
avancent en ordre dispersé et souvent
sans boussole
novembre dernier c'est le début de la
crise le cren
sous la forte pression de moscou en
refuse de signer un partenariat
privilégié avec l'union européenne
elle devait mener à une aide financière
de 610 millions d'euros à ce pays au
bord de la faillite
en échange de profondes réformes
économiques et de gouvernance moscou à
deux moyens de pression vis-à-vis de
kiev le gaz que la russie fournit à
l'ukraine elle pourrait couper le
robinet et les exportations ukrainiennes
vers le marché russe les marchandises
pourraient être bloqués à la frontière
si kiev persiste dans ses amours
européenne face à la pression russe
le président ianoukovitch cède le cred
est paralysé et certains craignent une
guerre civile entre pro européen et pro
russe face à cette situation
l'europe cherche une porte de sortie
vers le haut catherine ashton en est
convaincu la clé et financière une
grosse carotte la patronne de la
diplomatie européenne affirme que
l'union européenne les états unis
discutent à nouveau soutien qui ne sera
pas mince crème à bruxelles et dans
certaines capitales des voix s'élèvent
pour frapper un grand coup politique
le commissaire européen à
l'elargissement le tchèque stefan füle
plaide pour l'intégration de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne
plusieurs états membres surtout à l'est
du continent pologne roumanie et à malte
sont sur cette ligne
oui mais voilà la france les pays-bas et
l'allemagne sont vent debout contre tout
nouvel élargissement et voilà l'ukraine
qui s'enfonce dans la crise et des
européens qui ont contribué à la
déclencher d'avancer sans boussole est
en ordre dispersé
voilà on ukraine l'europe avance sans
boussole nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
marielle de sarnez bonjour vous êtes
eurodéputés vice présidente du modem
vous étiez vous-même en ukraine si je ne
m'abuse en décembre dernier en soutien
au peuple ukrainien qui manifestent quel
peuple vous avez rencontré c'était
extraordinaire sur la place maïdan
j'avais été pendant la révolution orange
et à ce moment là il y avait des
drapeaux orange partout évidemment et là
il y avait deux drapeaux chrétiens et
les drapeaux européens
c'est un peuple qui nous disait au fond
on a besoin de réformes
on a besoin de changement et vous pouvez
vous européen nous y aider et on a envie
plutôt de regarder vers l'europe que de
regarder vers la russie pour notre
avenir
c'est ça que j'ai vu et en même temps
c'est un peuple qui veut tourner la page
sur la corruption sur les oligarques
vous savez l'ukraine c'est un des pays
dans lequel la corruption le plus
important au monde on dit pas assez
donc c'est ça aussi les problèmes
craignant donc il ya beaucoup de
problèmes qui arrivent sur les
ukrainiens eh ben ils ont envie qu'on
soit là à leurs côtés pour les aider à
les régler mais n'inquiète pas tout à
fait d'accord avec vous moi c'est
vladimir poutine qui parle en parlant
des délégations européennes qui vont à
kiev 2 d'ingérence je le cite je ne peux
imaginer comment nos partenaires
européens réagirais si au plus fort
d'une crise dans un pays comme la grèce
ou chypre notre ministre des affaires
étrangères participait à un
rassemblement anti européen et commencé
à donner des conseils aux manifestants
dit poutine qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez
je pense qu'en matière d'ingérence ici
connaîtra très bien qu'en matière de
chantage ici connaîtra très bien dire
c'est d'ailleurs c'est lui qui fait un
chantage aux ukrainiens en permanence
avec la question du gaz vous savez bien
que depuis des années le prix du gaz qui
part de russie qui va en ukraine et qui
traversent l'ukraine est objet de
chantage c'est à dire que quand les
ukrainiens sont gentils on baisse le
prix du gaz quand ça va pas en montre le
prix du gaz
la vérité c'est que c'est aux ukrainiens
de choisir leur propre avenir
c'est pas à vladimir poutine et si les
ukrainiens ont envie de s'arrimer vers
l'europe et bien poutine doit les
laisser s'arrimer vers l'europe et je
vais même vous dire plus loin
la russie aussi fait partie du continent
européen donc nous avons tous intérêt à
avoir des relations on va dire stable et
respectueuse les uns des autres
donc ça rime et vert vers l'europe je
propose
d'écouter de regarder cette vidéo elle a
été postée sur le web elle fait elle
fait le buzz ce sont deux jeunes
ukrainiens qui manifestent dans les rues
de kiev et qui interpelle les grands de
ce monde les députés européens par
exemple on regarde et vous réagissez
juste après
et ciao bella center
quinn président of kings 16%
voilà la question est simple marielle de
sarnez quelles sanctions l'europe tous
les cas ils ont raison faut écouter ce
qu'ils nous disent ils ont envie
simplement de vivre dans un pays qui
soit en paix qui respecte avec un état
de droit qui respecte les libertés de
chacun ce qui n'est pas le cas en
ukraine qui met fin à la corruption ce
qui n'est pas le cas en ukraine est un
pays qui donne un avenir à ses enfants
qui donne des perspectives à ses enfants
il faut savoir que la semaine à l'europe
dans tous les cas il faut que ce pays se
réforme
il faut que l'europe l'y aide son
agriculture son industrie tout ça n'a
pas été modernisé depuis longtemps
depuis plusieurs années et même des
décennies
donc c'est un pays qui se portent mal
c'est un pays qui ne crée pas d'emplois
c'est un pays qui pourtant a des
richesses absolument très importante
probablement les richesses les plus
importantes de cette partie là de
l'europe
mais au fond il ne sait pas comment s'en
sortir comment moderniser son
agriculture comment moderniser son
économie
il faut qu'on aide à des investissements
il faut que ce pays donne des
perspectives à ses enfants
c'est ça que ces jeunes nous disent il
faut que l'europe soit là pour ça on l'a
on l'a dit le rappelle l avance un peu
sans boussole y en a d'un côté comme ce
commissaire européen à l'elargissement
qui eux d'une adhésion de l'ukraine à
l'europe il y en a qui veulent pas
parler pas entendre parler
d'élargissement c'est le cas de la
france celle 467 cas de l'allemagne
on n'y comprend rien et vous ne pouvons
pas aux ukrainiens en leur faisant
miroiter cette adhésion
c'est typiquement un faux débat la
question est pas adhésion ou pas les
ukrainiens ils veulent pas adhérer à
l'europe
ils veulent vivre en paix ils veulent
construire leur propre destin et si des
sanctions par exemple de l'europe à
l'égard des oligarques celle de tous
ceux qui se mettent tout l'argent dans
les poches depuis des années des années
et qui sont richissimes en ukraine si
des sanctions elles les ukrainiens alors
il faudra les prendre il faut que
l'europe soit moins timorés il faut que
l'europe s'assume telle qu'elle est
il regarde vers l'europe parce qu'ils
ont confiance en nous j'aimerais bien
que cette confiance ne soit pas démentie
dans les jours et les semaines qui
viennent parce qu'il faut un peu plus de
courage
la question par le passé pas de
politique à travers sa lésion pas des
ions l'ukraine
elle a son autonomie et moi je suis par
ailleurs pour qu'on réfléchisse le long
terme à une europe par cercles par
cercles concentriques à dire une europe
intégrée qui soit l'union européenne et
ensuite on peut avoir une politique de
voisinage intelligente avec les pays qui
sont au proximité de l'europe
mais si vous me demandez si l'europe a
une politique étrangère la réponse est
non mais si vous me demandez si je
souhaite qu'elle en aime beaucoup son
travail si on a besoin d'une politique
étrangère européenne on a besoin d'une
voix de l'europe et on a besoin que
l'europe quand les peuples comme ça
quand le peuple ukrainien attend d'elle
du courage que l'europe réponde présente
aux prochaines actions c'est quoi sur
place la situation j'espère peut-être y
retourner dans quelques dans quelques
jours dans quelques semaines je suis en
contact avec les familles de ceux qui
ont été arrêtés parce qu'il ya aussi une
atteinte aux libertés individuelles
on est à la limite d'un état qui
pourrait décréter une sorte d'état
d'urgence un certain greg guerre civile
on peut y arriver mais en tous les cas
moi je suis très inquiète
je pense qu'il faut être extrêmement
vigilant que les dernières lois qui ont
été prises tout ça ça ne va pas dans le
bon sens et que l'europe doit se montrer
intransigeante sur le respect des
libertés et des droits des ukrainiens
pour conclure vous pensez sincèrement
vous personnellement que le crâne elle
va s'arrimer à l'europe au détriment du
basque du grand frère alain son propre
destin elle a sa propre et vous perd sa
propre vie sa propre autonomie elle a
envie de regarder davantage va l'europe
mais je la comprends
ce que l'europe c'est un état de droit
l'europe allait critiquer chez nous mais
il faut que vous sachiez que à
l'extérieur elle est vécue comme au fond
une grande zone de stabilité comme une
grande zone de droit comme une zone de
développement économique de progrès
social ça n'existe nulle part de la même
manière dans le monde et donc cette
europe là elle fait envie et a coûté
soyons aux côtés des ukrainiens leur
avenir il est de toute façon dans ce
continent européen au côté de l'europe
et avec l'europe
merci marielle de sarnez d'avoir accepté
notre invitation et maintenant place aux
reportages direction la belgique fini
l'impunité sur sur les routes depuis
novembre dernier les automobilistes ne
pourront plus faire l'impasse sur les
contraventions contractée dans un autre
pays de l'union européenne c'est
l'europe des pv est ce que ça tient la
route
pas si sûr c'est ce qu'à aller voir
notre envoyé spécial sur les routes de
belgique
françois moulin
une mauvaise surprise attend les
automobilistes français ce matin
à peine ont-ils passé la frontière à
tournai une patrouille de la police
belge arrêtent leur véhicule et un
simple appel radio suffit pour vérifier
l'identité du propriétaire
cette efficacité est le résultat d'une
directive européenne entrée en action en
novembre dernier 25 pays de l'union
signée
résultat un fichier informatique commun
où l'on trouve les coordonnées de tous
les conducteurs du continent et que
cette vitesse téléphone au volant ou
feux rouges
désormais les amendes sont envoyés
directement dans la boîte aux lettres du
propriétaire de la voiture
les frontaliers interpellés qui découvre
le nouveau système sont sceptiques
je pense que c'est une question pour
gagner du pognon est essentiellement
omar est les plaques françaises
sans ça j'en suis convaincu quand on est
français on est obligé de payer parce
qu'après ça allait poursuite beaucoup
plus importante
à tournai où près de 20 % des
infractions routières sont justement
commises par des étrangers
la directive est la bienvenue même si la
police constate que son effet est limité
on a une facilitation de notre travail
journalier dans le cadre de la rédaction
des procès verbaux mais ça ne fait pas
diminuer le nombre d'infractions
ça ne change pas la mentalité et le
comportement des conducteurs que ce soit
étranger et pour cause
la directive ne prévoit aucun moyen pour
contraindre les conducteurs à payer leur
amende
elle ne prévoit pas non plus la perte de
points sur le permis cet avocat parisien
connaît bien les limites judiciaire de
ces pv venus de l'étranger
il vient justement d'en recevoir un d'un
client flashé en suisse en cas de non
paiement de l'amendé ou de non réponse
au présent courrier sous 10 jours
vous vous exposez au risque d'être
interpellée sur le territoire suisse en
vue du recouvrement du montant en
question face aux menaces
son conseil est simple pour les
automobilistes même pas peur
même pas peur parce qu'en réalité il
n'ya aucun pouvoir de coercition concret
derrière c'est de la poudre aux yeux
c'est qu'en réalité on veut terroriser
l'automobiliste en lui disant on va vous
verbaliser on va vous sanctionner on va
vous poursuivre mais en réalité se
passera pas grand chose
oui l'état va envoyer éventuellement des
avis de contravention par le courrier
mais il se passera rien d'autre derrière
parce que la directive ne prévoit pas
ses possibilités de recouvrement il faut
pour cela des accords de coopération
judiciaire entre chaque état une
coopération judiciaire est en
préparation jure-t-on au ministère de
l'intérieur
mais la priorité est de traduire les
différents pv en 24 langues pour qu'ils
soient valides
seuls cinq pays reçoivent pour l'instant
les contraventions françaises dans leur
langue et l'hexagone est un des pays les
plus avancés sur la question il faut que
nous soyons parfaitement certains de
faire en sorte que cette amende soit
recouvrer jusqu'au bout c'est à dire que
les gens sachent que si je ne paye pas
malgré tout je serai entre guillemets
poursuivi jusqu'au bout jusqu'à ce que
je paie on veut pas récolté d'argent on
veut travailler pour la sécurité
routière et que tout le monde finalement
comprenne qu'il vaut mieux respecter les
limitations de vitesse
vaut mieux s'arrêter au feu rouge vaut
mieux respecter les règles tout le monde
s'en portera que mieux et on ne rend pas
besoin de tout cet arsenal là aussi le
principal défaut de la directive n'est
pas encore résolu le fait que le
propriétaire de la voiture soit
verbalisé et non le conducteur l'amande
peut être contestées il faut adresser un
courrier aux autorités dans la langue du
pays concerné puis se rendre devant la
juridiction locale pour expliquer son
cas
pas sûr que beaucoup de contrevenants ne
fasse le déplacement
voilà un reportage de françois goulens
nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
nathalie griesbeck bonjour vous êtes au
député mouvement des démocrates ou
d'être spécialiste des questions sur la
sécurité routière à vos côtés saïd el
kardaoui bonjour vous êtes eurodéputés
belges du groupe socialiste et vous êtes
membre de la commission des transports
vous connaissez aussi bien le dossier
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
toute simple à quoi elle sert cette
directive est ce que fondamentalement
c'est une révolution dans l'histoire de
la sécurité routière en europe à partir
du moment où on a le principe de
mobilité entre les états membres donc la
mobilité des travailleurs la mobilité la
liberté d'aller et venir
c'est assez logique aussi qui est une
forme d'égalité dans l'usagé
l'utilisation des infrastructures moi je
viens d'une grande région l'est de la
france qui est une région par définition
frontalières où il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de nos amis européens d'autres états
membres qui circulent parfois à tombeau
ouvert
sauf qu'il ya une forme d'égalité en ce
qui concerne
là la sanction des infractions mais il
ya des lacunes dans on en parlera sayyid
al qardaoui cette directive pourquoi il
ya clairement un sentiment d'impunité
sceller les chauffeurs qui se rendent à
l'étranger par exemple en touche en
allemagne ne veut pas voir en moyenne
500 ddd chauffeurs sont d'origine
étrangère d un acquis qui parcourt les
routes en europe et 15% des excès de
vitesse
donc vous voyez c'est il ya trois fois
plus de chance en tant que chauffeur à
l'étranger de rouler trop rapidement et
donc il faut trouver des moyens france
20% et on est passé d'un plus caché aux
coûts de transit et ses légendes et
automobile en france est encore pire
et donc il faut trouver des solutions et
la directive qu'on a adopté en 2011 et
qui maintenant est mise en place est un
premier pas et c'est vrai qu'il ya
encore des problèmes à régler c'est la
raison pour laquelle leur parlement nous
avons obtenu qu'en 2016 la commission
vient avec un rapport avec des
conclusions et éventuellement avec une
nouvelle va parler de ces améliorations
plus tard moi je vais rester très
concrets pour que nos téléspectateurs
comprennent bien
un peu cher c'est de dire est ce cette
directive est ce qu'on pourra contester
première question toute simple se pose
peut se poser un automobiliste européen
est ce qu'on pourra contester ces pv
évidemment on peut les contester devant
un juge
et donc c'est vrai qu'il ya des
différences parce qu'il ya certains
états qui ont des permis à points
d'autres ils n'en ont pas nous on a des
permis à points on perd non seulement on
paie donc l'infraction commise et en
plus on perd des points au général donc
ça il n'y a pas pour l'instant de
l'harmonisation y apprendra dans les
deux langues o sinon il semblerait que
sa seule joie susceptible d'être résolue
il y aura des formulaires dans l'est
dans les langues des états membres et ça
pourra aller vite la transmission aussi
par les moyens technologiques numériques
ce sera faisable
ensuite si elle a effectivement le
recours possible donc vous avez un
recours devant le juge
on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans votre
reportage fort bien fait à la fois par
la dame qui dit le seul moyen de gagner
du pognon
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
malchance fric non j'ai enfin c'est sans
doute on le voit en france à moi je suis
française on est quand même on est très
très surveillé avec les radars embarqués
avec les radars mobiles en france je
crois qu'il ya plus de quatre mille
radars on s'occupe de la sécurité méga
quand même il faut le dire
des résultats pas en matière de poids
lourds ou les accidents restent très
nombreux et mortelle mais en ce qui
concerne la circulation
classique il ya quand même une
diminution du nombre de blessés et de
tués
c'est quand même un résultat en matière
de sécurité donc je reviens pas aux
reportages on voit que des recours
possible simplement c'est compliqué il
faut que ce soit dans votre état est et
surtout si vous n'êtes pas poursuivis et
que vous pouviez ajouté lagardère
édition c'est compliqué oui
tout d'abord c'est vrai que les mesures
et pas seulement cette mesure si mais
beaucoup de mesures qui ont été prises
les dernières années
vous contribuez à la décrue du nombre de
tués par exemple entre 2000 et 2010 on a
une évolution de 50 milles vers trente
mille tués sur les routes par an donc il
faut continuer ses efforts lui mais la
dirif direct depuis depuis trois mois
mais voilà voilà donc donc ça pourrait
aider à continuer la baisse c'est ça le
but de tim bien sûr et puis il ya bien
sûr des problèmes nous avons lorsque
nous avions négocié avec le conseil déjà
miss et revient sur la table mais les
états ne sont pas encore prêts à aller
plus loin aujourd'hui peut-être ça
viendra mais par exemple sur le fait que
en fin de compte comme la rockhal à
l'exprimer vous ne vous ne devez pas
paix parce que personne ne va vous la
question secrète sais pas si on ne paye
pas tout simplement la prochaine fois
que vous venez dans ce pays et vous êtes
attrapé dans le fichier il est clair il
sera quand même vraiment indiqué que
vous devez encore payer une pénalité
n'importe quoi et ça va vous coûter plus
cher et peut-être vous aurez plus de
problèmes à la donc si vous ne payez pas
c'est clair qu'on va vous pas vous
emprisonner tout de suite on va pas vous
cherchez dans votre pays mais si vous
revenez dans le pays
vous avez fait la faute ah bah vous
allez payer quand même c'est tout simple
si je reprends l'exemple très concret
puisque c'est très important c'est le
quotidien les gens dans ma région la
lorraine
il ya 80 milles frontaliers donc qui
tous les jours sont sûres sont sur l'a31
avec des limitations de vitesse qui sont
parfois limités de manière naturelle
étant donné qu'il ya des bouchons mais
donc les gens si ils essaient de passer
entre les gouttes de la loi en disant je
paie pas puisque donc le ressort
territorial judiciaire n'est pas dans le
pays où je vis c'est risquer quand même
puisque tous les jours ils traversent la
frontière
donc je crois que ça quand même à la
fois un effet en matière de sécurité en
effet dissuasif et une forme je le redis
d'égalité moi quand je vois des voitures
dont je tairai la marque assez à toute
berzingue à côté de moi alors qu'ils
sont flashés et qui se disent tant pis
il ya une forme de contradiction de la
vie en europe de notre quotidien c'est
une puissance moyenne c'est une question
de l'harmonisation européenne vous
parlais justement de cet avocat
vous avez vu dans le reportage la madame
la députée monsieur le député vous
interpelle
on l'écouté vous réagissez juste après
alors que l'europe a été construite sur
le pilier qui est celui de la libre
circulation des personnes
comment sait-il que 50 ans après il n'y
ait pas eu de consensus politique pour
harmoniser l'ensemble des règles de
circulation et de répression des
infractions au code de la route parce
que force est de constater que les
règles de circulation sont totalement
disparate d'un état à un autre
voilà pourquoi il n'ya pas
d'harmonisation des délits en europe et
en france le taux d'alcoolémie des taux
d'alcoolémie autorisé c'est 0,5 gramme
par litre en hongrie c'est tolérance
zéro slovaquie c'est tolérance zéro
pourquoi n'y a pas cette harmonisation
je pense qu'il n'y a pas de volonté
politique aujourd'hui au sein des états
membres d'harmoniser au niveau européen
parce qu'il préfère garder ce genre de
décision chez eux 30 chez eux et ne pas
avoir un système harmonisé
mais par contre je pense que la tendance
est la même
la tendance de baisser la limite de
vitesse maximale de baisser le taux
d'alcool trop c'est la même chose mais
me voilà donc il ya quand même si on
regarde les chiffres dépit des
différents pays membres on voit une
tendance
disons des règles plus strictes dans
tous les sens du mot et je pense que sur
certains points on pourrait imaginer
dans quelques années commence et il sort
d'une forme d'harmonisation il ya déjà
des fondeurs d'harmonisation sur par
exemple les critères sur le comment la
structure doit être fait
1 ceux d'autres aspects dans le dans le
contexte chauffeur routier par exemple
il ya quand même des règles harmonisées
à des temps de repos etc qui sont
contrôlés d'une façon harmonisée
mais pas encore vraiment pour les
passagers
ordinaire qu'on vous et moi et ça ira
peut-être plus vite que quelques années
mais en même temps on est au coeur des
contradictions
en europe c'est à dire que on voudrait
plus d'intégration plus d'harmonisation
et en même temps on dit à l'europe
écoutez vous allez pas vous mêlez de
savoir si sur la rn 4 131 il faut rouler
à 90 à l'heure comme sur le ring de
bruxelles
on nous dira c'est à dire on est
toujours coincé dans ce dilemme alors
que nous on est à mon avis on est habité
par l'idée qui vaudrait mieux avoir une
règle le plus harmoniser la plus
harmonisées possibles et le plus vite
possible pour ça ça demande une
coopération en termes effectivement de
législation entre les états membres on a
des législations qui sont différentes
donc il faut qu'on approfondit gardien
mais il ya aussi des différences disons
dans la réalité de tous les jours en
suède par exemple les longues distances
de jeu et ils ne vont pas accepter de se
dire que l'on va on va limiter la
vitesse d'affichage 70 à l'heure tandis
que dans des dans des zones très
urbanisées bien sûr il ya le jeu juste
nous un rapport à la suède ou à la
finlande effectivement où vous êtes sur
500 600 km dans une très très belle
forêt où ils ont envie d'utiliser les
petits gars là il enseignait les jolies
camions américains rutilant mais qui
détruisent les routes qui sont des vrais
mastodonte qui font peur sur les
autoroutes
eh bien nous par exemple nous en france
qui sommes carrefour moi je suis vent
debout contre la mise en oeuvre de ces
poids lourds et je vous dirai c'est sur
ces directives les finlandaises ont
envie parce que ils sont mort dur
externe de leur revenir à cette
directive quand on attrape donc on
attrape généralement le
le propriétaire du véhicule assez des
plaques d'immatriculation qui sont
échangées le propriétaire du véhicule ce
n'est pas forcément le conducteur fait
donc on vous envoie le questionnaire est
en france oui cela et vous devez vous
devez répondre voilà et vous devez vous
dites moi c'était pas moi elle
s'applique aussi en france entend entre
entre belges entre français vous pouvez
très bien être dans votre véhicule être
en infraction le moins souvent possible
et donc dire que c'était quelqu'un
d'autre qui conduisait apparemment mais
c'est pas permis
mais ce que vous répondez à cette dame
dans le reportage qui dit que finalement
ce n'est pas une s'occupa forcément de
la sécurité de la sécurité de l'europe
et est une question d'argent une
question de pognon comme elle dit elle
le report des quoi j'ai répondu au début
il ya beaucoup plus d'un trafic
d'infraction commis par des étrangers
que par les nationaux donc si enfin par
cette législation
et on pourrait équilibrer disons les
choses il y aurait moins d'excès de
vitesse et dans plus de sécurité
routière au dernier mot comprendre que
la dame elle était plutôt française et
c'est vrai qu'en france il y a
une propension à vraiment être très très
très contrôlé non moi je vais à
bruxelles en voiture des pannes
sentiment que le roi me retire mon
permis de conduire
mais en france il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de contrôle et donc en france tout est
une question de mesure la démocratie
c'est une question d'équilibré et la
sicile en a trop fait les gens merci en
tout cas à vous d'avoir accepté notre
invitation c'est la fin de rome merci
c'est la fin d'euro pub de la semaine
prochaine vous retrouvez nous ramadi à
cette même place
en attendant bonne suite des programmes
sur les chaînes parlementaires
on se souvient de ces as du retentissant
mais lorsque valéry giscard d